Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse has finally
arrived in theaters, giving everyone a chance
to dig into one of the most anticipated movies
of the year.
The movie is also fairly complex, blending
a massive cast of characters with different
animation styles, multiple villains, and a
plot line that hops dimensions.
If you're still trying to figure it all out,
we're here to help.
Oh, and that weird feeling?
That's your spoiler sense tingling.
"Hey guys."
"Wanda?"
"Gwen, actually."
"Oh, you know her.
Very cool."
From the moment she's revealed as in the film,
Gwen Stacy makes it clear that she's not interested
in making friends.
Of course, that changes over the course of
the film, and by the end she's definitely
interested in a friendship with Miles Morales.
Luckily, these spider pals have figured out
a way to stay in touch across dimensions,
when she seems to visit him right before the
credits roll.
The film doesn't take the time at the end
to explain why or how this is actually happening,
but it's an obvious setup for a Spider-gang
in the inevitable sequel.
Miles Morales learns throughout the film that
he can't just be Spider-Man in some kind of
magic, automatic way.
He has to take the leap of faith and become
Spider-Man in a way that's true to him.
We see this in a thrilling sequence in which
he creates his own Spider-suit and heads out
into the world with his own unique threads.
In the final moments of the film, we see that
he's continued his street art tradition both
as Miles and as Spider-Man.
In the end, Miles carries on the long tradition
of refusing to kill his nemesis, and instead
turns Kingpin over to the authorities.
We know two things about this universe's Kingpin
for sure: He has considerable resources, and
he is absolutely relentless in his pursuit
of getting what he wants.
Chances are that what he wants most after
the credits is vengeance upon the new Spider-Man.
Don't be surprised if he manages to show up
in some fashion in a sequel.
Into the Spider-Verse is largely Miles' story,
but he's not the only Spider-Man to learn
a lesson.
In teaching Miles how to use his powers, Peter
B. Parker also re-learns the lessons of great
power and great responsibility that he had
to internalize all those years ago.
"We're a little team!
Me as the teacher who can still do it.
You as the student who can do it but not as
well.
I'm proud of us!"
When we first meet him, he's a Spider-Man
on auto-pilot, shrugging his way through crime-fighting
while his personal life is in shambles.
In meeting Miles, he finds an opportunity
to teach and to learn about what it is to
be a hero all over again.
By the time he returns to his home universe,
he's a changed man.
Not just an Amazing Spider-Man, but an amazing
man.
A couple of months before Into the Spider-Verse
hit theaters, Sony released another film based
on a Marvel Comics character with a very close
Spider-Man connection: Venom.
That film included two post-credits scenes,
one of which seemed to be just an extended
clip to promote Into the Spider-Verse, which
included an important title card telling us
that the upcoming animated film was taking
place "In another universe."
Does this mean that Tom Hardy's Venom could
show up in future installments of the Spider-Verse
franchise?
"I HAVE PROOF!”
The answer is a definite...maybe.
But that would be a truly wild crossover indeed.
Miles' father Jefferson is a police officer
who views Spider-Man as a menace — until,
that is, he sees the new Spider-Man in action
at the end of the film.
His very vocal change of heart during the
final battle helps Miles to defeat Kingpin,
and Miles returns the favor by finally telling
his dad he loves him — well, sort of.
"Officer, I love you."
"haha, wait, what?"
It's a big emotional payoff in the film, giving
Miles the opportunity to covertly tell his
father what he's been holding back.
It might also be the new Spider-Man accidently
hinting at his identity.
If that's the case, it might not be long before
Miles is outed as Spider-Man to his parents.
In the end, Miles Morales is able to send
all of his friends back home and defeat Kingpin.
Still, this is a superhero universe with a
sequel on the way, so we know his version
of New York City won't stay quiet for long.
So who will Miles fight the next time around?
The clear contender could be the Green Goblin,
who shows up in this film for its first major
fight scene but is ultimately relegated to
a minor role.
We're betting the Green Goblin, and his alter
ego Norman Osborn, could have a much larger
role to play in the sequel.
The film's post-credits scene reveals yet
another Spider-hero, as we see a costumed
figure named Miguel jump into the past and
get in an argument with the Spider-Man from
the 1967 animated series.
The Miguel in question is Miguel O'Hara, a.k.a.
Spider-Man 2099.
In the comics and in the film, he has the
ability to hop through dimensions, which means
he could show up alongside any of Into the
Spider-Verse's heroes at a moment's notice.
Keep an eye out for him in the follow-up.
Of course, we all know who we really want
to come back next time we visit the Spider-Verse:
"I just washed my hands, that's why they're
wet.
No other reason."